ich habe heute wieder mal gelesen dass
die Briefwahl so boomt dass 60%
mutmaßlich an dieser Wald per Briefwahl
teilnehmen und finde es irritierend dass
es darüber wenig Diskussionen oder gar
Empörung gibt weil ich finde Briefwahl
in dieser Größenordnung des
undemokratisch wenn mehr als die Hälfte
der Menschen sich so viel früher
festlegen dann gibt es ein verzerrtes
Bild des Wettbewerbsverzerrung und ich
kann es auch begründen sogar aus der
Idee einer Wahl heraus die sollen
nämlich frei und gleich sein geheim auch
jetzt machen wir mal bei frei ist sie
geheim ist sie per Brief wahrscheinlich
auch aber sie ist nicht gleich weil
zugleich gehört natürlich auch der
gleiche Tag an dem alle abstimmen wenn
ich mir vorstelle was jetzt bis zum 26
September noch alles passieren kann was
all diejenigen die jetzt schon wählen
gar nicht mehr in ihre Wahlentscheidung
mit einbeziehen können mache ich mir
Sorgen ob da überhaupt ein Ergebnis
rauskommt das mit der Realität wirklich
etwas zu tun hat also
ich finde das ziemlich rückwärtsgewandte
so zu sehen weil was sind die kennt die
Schweiz auch schon ein bisschen weil die
dort gearbeitet habe zumindest teilweise
und dort funktioniert ganz wunderbar und
vor allem ein Punkt bei der Briefwahl
ist ja dass die die Wahlbeteiligung
gesteigert wird und ich finde das ein
total ist super für das Individuum
selbst entscheiden zu können waren die
wählen die ich sehe den Punkt dass man
das manche Dinge nicht wissen kann aber
dann müsste man vielleicht über den
Zeitraum sprechen oder in dem eine
Wahlmöglichkeit aber und über die ich
finde Entschuldigung und die Menge es
gibt zum Beispiel eine klare Erkenntnis
darüber dass wenn alle per briefwählen
würden würde das
Bundesverfassungsgericht damit nicht
konform gehen meine These lautet wenn es
60% sind sind wir näher an alle als an
dem Ursprungsgedanken dass jemand der am
Wahltag weiß dass er nicht an seinem Ort
ist oder der nicht ins Wahllokal gehen
kann dafür war die Briefwahl ja
ursprünglich gedacht ich glaube dass sie
in gewisser Weise zweckentfremdet ist
und wir noch gar nicht uns richtig klar
machen was das bedeutet ich finde es ist
auch ein ungeheure Bequemlichkeit muss
ich sagen es gibt natürlich in
corona-zeiten gewisse Argumente dafür
man will da nicht hin aber da würde ich
sagen bei unserer Impfquote und die
Möglichkeit da machen Leute die stehen
auch beim Bäcker an da kann man auch mal
im Wahllokal angehen für mich die
schönste Anekdote die schönste Anekdote
übers wählen in den USA wird ja immer
dienstags gewählt weil Sonntag Kirche
ist und dann braucht man noch den Montag
um zum nächsten Wahllokal zu reiten und
deswegen wird am Dienstag gewählt und
das zeigt das Wahl halt auch manchmal
etwas mit Mühe zu tun hat und dass
unsere Demokratie diese Mühe eben wert
ist und ich kann für mich sagen es gibt
doch wenn man sich irgendwie für unsere
Gesellschaft für Politik für dieses Land
interessiert und ich sage das als jemand
der Wahlen gecovert hat bei den Menschen
sich in die Luft gesprengt aber die
Leute ihr Leben riskiert haben und sie
es gibt doch nichts schöneres als an
diesem Sonntag vom Wahllokal zu stehen
fantastisch und die gehen wirklich auch
immer hin aber meine halt dass man also
ganz grundsätzlich die Briefwahl in
Zweifel zu ziehen ich glaube aber da
sind wir uns wahrscheinlich eh einig das
ist
dann über die Konditionen eben also wie
viel Zeit kann da vorher Vergehen also
das ist nicht vier Wochen sind und was
nicht Frau Berber hat noch fünf Fehler
in ihrem Lebenslauf oder solche Dinge
oder
ja genau oder macht wirklich einfach
gerichtet Punkt oder eine Partei stellt
plötzlich noch einen neuen Kandidaten
Punkt
von Klaus ist doch das gleich ja und
gleich hat ja das kann man ja finde ich
sehr stressig argumentieren durchaus
etwas mit gleichzeitig zu tun ich habe
gleich viel Zeit für meine Thesen zu
werden totale Briefwahl heute ist
vermutlich das Albtraum guten Vorschlag
gehört wie es seinen muss ich sagen ich
wundere mich das darüber nicht viel
offener und öffentlich diskutiert wird
denn sie haben gesagt das hat was auch
mit ein bisschen Mühe zu tun da
hinzugehen das sehe ich gar nicht die
das wahllokales im Regelfall zwei
Straßen weitere höchstens man geht da
macht ein kleinen Spaziergang hin es ist
ein Ritual sondern das meine ich dann
Rituale Demokratie alles mit dem stimme
ich überein außerdem geht es natürlich
auch um ein paar andere Vokabeln zu
machen es geht um Bruder des wahlakts
und würde der Demokratie und um Respekt
vor den ganzen Vorgang und das ist doch
spannend zu sehen wenn man da im
Wahllokal steht dass man da mit allen
möglichen Menschen zusammensteht die
sind an dem Tag alle gleich und sehen
sich und man sieht die Menschen die sich
die Mühe machen die Zettel zu zählen um
diesen Zettel dann drüber zu schieben
damit niemand anderes was man ist doch
man wechselt ein Wort mit den
Wahlhelfern und fragt wie viel waren
denn schon da und wenn man da rausgeht
aus dem Wahllokale Rechnung ja wenn man
rausgeht hat man sich ein erhobenes
Gefühl man hat was sind FDP-Wähler
eigentlich brieffehler auch aber nicht
nur und viele haben auch Respekt vor dem
Wahlakt sie stellt uns gerade Ehrenamt
Wahlhelfer ganz wichtig aber ich glaube
wir haben wir haben insgesamt in der
Gesellschaft so eine Haltung ein
bisschen Demokratie als Versandhaus zu
sehen das zu konsumieren ist man sowas
wenn am wenn am Sonntag gutes Wetter ist
dann macht man was anderes geht nicht
zur Wahl oder geht macht vorher
Briefwahl also ich glaube es ist genau
die Frage würde respekt das wahlakts
andere Menschen in der Welt werden froh
wenn sie es dürften und das ist bei uns
einfach zu sehr Routine geworden zu sehr
gut wird eigentlich alle vier Jahre auf
diesem Stichtag genau nicht auch gewählt
damit es eben genau diesen diesen
stichtagmoment gibt damit man eben genau
diese Zeit hat bis dahin zu
argumentieren
aber wofür also wie viel Prozent
brieffehler werden denn für dich noch
immernehmbar 60 70 80 eben eine Mehrheit
ist wahrscheinlich wirklich dann
Demokratie politisch bedenklich aber
solange es nicht an den 60 kratzt wie
gesagt vor allem jetzt in diesen Zeiten
kann man sowieso findet das schwer
beurteilen weil durch Corona ob wir
jetzt geimpft sind und uns das nicht
mehr so viel ausmacht ist okay aber es
gibt jetzt trotzdem noch viele Menschen
die vularabisch sind oder nicht machen
wollen und können und ich verstehe alle
Argumente es ist genauso und ich bin wie
gesagt auch ein sehr find wie ein
fantastisch trotzdem will das gerne
jedem Einzelnen überlassen ob es machen
will vielleicht gibt es Menschen die das
nicht zu sehen und die gerne einfach
lieber diesen Brief abschicken warum
auch immer und die wird sie nicht
absprechen wollen das war ja mal anders
in Deutschland bis 2008 glaube war das
nicht möglich es sei denn man war
ernsthaft behindern
eine Theorie zur Briefwahl ich glaube es
finden besonders die Leute Briefwahl
toll die bei Oma gerne die Grünen also
ich habe das Gefühl dass das Briefwahl
ein ein ganz großes Phänomen geworden
ist von Leuten die gerne für Ihre
Familie entscheiden wollen und
überprüfen wollen und es dann auch
übrigens noch Twitter oder beim
betrunkenen Sohn der erst spät nach
Hause gekommen ist kreuzen Sie CDU an ja
schon aber das ist ja schon also ich
meine das ist ja also bei der bei der an
der Ordner an der Wahl ohne wird ja
tatsächlich sehr streng überprüft ob ich
da alleine drin bin das ist ja was was
flächendeckend wegfällt auf einmal da
wird dann am Frühstückstisch auf einmal
und ich muss sagen selber die Momente
wir erleben das ja schon wenn bei der
Auszählung von stimmen auch bei
ausländischen Wahlen dann gesagt wird da
kommen aber noch die die
Briefwahlstimmen dazu entweder sind die
schon ausgezählt keiner weiß aber im
Ergebnis darf ja noch nicht gesagt
werden oder sie werden erst später
ausgezählt in USA haben wir das gesehen
aber der bei der Trump Abwahl spielt das
eine relativ große Rolle das ist völlig
undurchschaubar was sich da abspielt ob
die genau richtig bei dem was die Frage
sind die genau richtig gezählt das muss
wird bei uns nicht das Problem sein aber
das ist da was gibt dass wir nicht
kennen das nicht gleich zugänglich ist
dass wenn ich gleich verstehen dass
irgendwann dazu kommt finde ich ganz
schrecklich
wer von euch hat schon mal Briefwahl
gemacht ich habe noch nicht ich war
immer da jemand am Tisch schon mal
gemacht weil ich nicht da war ja ist
eben immer die muss jetzt auch wenn in
Österreich wählen will dann achso ja gut
in Österreich ja für wen würde dieses
Thema im Moment wer für Wert Briefwahl
gerade mehr zu fürchten ist das ist das
Lasche doch naja weil es war in den USA
die Frage also wem nutzt Briefwahl
eigentlich mehr in den USA was hier ganz
klar Joe Biden der Trump erst ganz
deutlich vorne und die beiden Leute
haben immer gesagt wartet ab the blue
search das kommt noch wenn die
Briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt werden ja
also ich finde es auch ein wichtiger
Unterschied was wir gerade besprochen
haben Respekt vor dem eigentlichen
Wahlakt von dieser wirklichen
Gleichzeitigkeit einerseits aber auch
nicht Stimmung machen das macht die AFD
Misstrauen bewusst jetzt zu sehen dass
generell Briefwahl Instrument sei
irgendwie Wahlen zu manipulieren und das
eben ein schmaler Grad ich finde wir
müssen genaueres den Respekt die würde
wieder stärken dass die Wertschätzung
für diesen Wahlakt und dass wir da diese
mitbestimmungsmöglich Vorteil hat
der aktuell vorne liegt weil der wird da
wird er gerne sehen dass wir jetzt für
Scholz ja wenn alle Scholze partisanten
jetzt schon wählen ja ja
noch erreichen kann wird ja durch
Briefwahl immer kleiner sozusagen
also die sind wirklich schon festgelegt
ja alle anderen die sagen wir haben
wissen schon was wir könnten aber die
die gewählt haben sind ja schon
festgelegt die sind schon in Ordnung ja
und das übrigens finde ich für die
Demokratie nach wie vor als der
schlimmsten Worte dass man seine
hochheilige Stimme in einem oberen
Wahlordnung also das ist für mich das
habe ich das wird schwierig insofern
insofern ist Briefwahl warum haben die
SPD so auf Briefwahl gesetzt warum haben
die diese aktivierungskampagne so massiv
gefahren die Scheine zu glauben dass
Briefwahl in Notfall Laschet im Moment
so lasch da steht oder na eben genau aus
dem Grund glaube das könnte jetzt doch
noch was ändern und diese Stimme ist
einfach geholt wahrscheinlich Lehrer die
die SPD wählen Angst haben zu gehen wenn
Corona oder so großer ordentlich Alter
Anhängerschaft inzwischen das vielleicht
weiß ich jetzt nicht genau soziologisch
aber älter als die von anderen Parteien
und das muss gleich organisiert werden
damit man den die Scheune fahren kann
fand ich übrigens apropos alte
Wählerschaft und total spannenden Punkt
CW Umfrage haben wir vorhin kurz drüber
gesprochen der Kandidat der unter seinen
eigenen WLAN beim Trail am schlechtesten
abgeschnitten hat auch da Armin Laschet
in den niedrigen 70ern Olaf Scholz und
Annalena beerburg beide über 80 und aus
meiner Sicht auch absolut dramatisch
dass die Älteren wählersegmente in
dieser Umfrage nicht mehr CDU wählen wie
kommt es denn dazu wenn das Schlimmste
im Sport ist wenn deine eigenen Fans
dich aus Pfeifen das ist das was
sozusagen Armin Laschet jetzt erlebt wir
wenden sich ab und ich meine ich bis aus
meinem eigenen Bekanntenkreis und und
und Freundeskreis das wirklich
hartgesottene Unionswähler irgendwie
sowas sagen wie
dann werden wir diesmal halt grün es hat
für sie manche sein bestimmt das wird
zwar furchtbar ganz schlimm aber wenn
dann machen wir es jetzt mal bloß damit
dieser Mann sozusagen ich kann es laut
wird weil das geht gar nicht auch für
die SPD die Freunde nämlich also die
einfach sagen natürlich sind aus diesem
Effekt die Stimmen für für grün und auch
die FDP äh ja praktisch messbar also ja
abschließende Frage an Uli Jörg ist und
andere Schneider sie sind parteiisch
Klaus arbeitet hier ich auch wer gewinnt
die Wahl David Bundeskanzler muss ich
mir jetzt festlegen zwei einfache Worte
Sebastian Kurz
[Musik]
seit gestern sagt auch Ulrichs Olaf
Scholz zwei einfache Worte
[Musik]